total I've a feeling we're not in Kansas
anymore
some people build fences to keep people
out and other people build fences to
keep people in fasten your seatbelts
it's gonna be a bumpy night the stuff
that dreams are made of
unforgettable lines created by brilliant
screenwriters this year's nominated
writers by adding their unique voices
gave new life to novels memoirs and
characters from comic books and movies
here are the nominees for Best Adapted
Screenplay call me by your name
screenplay by James ivory based on the
novel by Andre ASIMO the disaster
artists screenplay by Scott Neustadter
and Michael H Weber based on the book
the disaster artist my life inside the
room the greatest bad movie ever made by
Greg Sestero and Tom Bissell Logan
screenplay by Scott Frank and James
Mangold and Michael Greene story by
James Mangold based on characters
created by Lynn Wien and John Romita
senior
Molly's game written for the screen by
Aaron Sorkin based on the book by Molly
bloom mud bound screenplay by Virgil
Williams and Elise based on the novel by
Hilary Jordan and the Oscar goes to
this is the first
if screenwriter James IV
and as previously nominated
[Applause]
well I'll try and keep it slow make it
as fast as I can or the music plays my
rule number one for a screenwriter who
adapts a novel his first sank the author
Andrew simon who wrote the story about
first love and who's here tonight they
store familiar to most of us whether is
straight or gay are somewhere in between
we've all gone through first love I hope
I come out the other side mostly intact
so maybe not without the benefit of
loving parents like the Perlman's in
this film I want to thank our sensitive
and sensible director Luca Guadagnino as
well as my neighbors in upstate New York
Peter stairs and Brian Schwartzman who
offered me this job and of course I want
to thank the film's wonderful emotions
filled actress I wouldn't be standing
here tonight without their inspired help
and I wouldn't be standing up here
without the inspired help I received
from my life's partners who are gone our
writer Ruth chavala who received this
award twice and our fearless producer is
Mountain urgent working with them for
close to 50 years of mercenaries led me
to this award and my profound thanks to
the members of the Academy in voting for
me you are remembering them and finally
my thanks to Sony classics to Michel
Barker and to Tom Barnard for getting
behind this film in such a princely way
thank you very much everyone
[Applause]